for these specialist
firearms officers this is a high risk
operation
the use of flash bang distraction
devices
a vital tactic in subduing potentially
dangerous suspects
[Music]
they're targeting a traveler's site in
southeast london
where it's believed and organized gang
are supplying firearms to criminals
across the capitol
overhead a police helicopter and police
drone
relayed live pictures of the raids to
the met special operations center
in central london we were allowed to
witness that
unfolding operation as news came through
that a number of the key suspects had
been detained
uh detectives are about to make an
arrest at the venue
they require additional resources as um
they
um see two on scene um possibly require
a few more offices
there's a lot of fast moving parts in an
operation like this we've managed to get
onto the site we now have control of the
site and
indeed we've located a number of the
individuals that we were looking to
speak to
this was one of the biggest operations
of its kind in recent years
several hundred personnel including
counter-terrorism specialist
firearms officers an elite unit brought
in not for any terrorist threat
but because of their tactical expertise
in handling highly dangerous situations
the raids come against the backdrop of a
very worrying spike in firearms offences
twice the number of shootings since the
lifting of the lockdown
compared to the same period last year
this
is the sort of operation that we need to
be doing to tackle violence
in the capital one of the things around
this operation is that we're looking to
get to the supply
of weapons and ammunition that are used
in the streets of london and get them at
source
and to actually stop them from getting
onto the streets of london and into the
hands of the wrong people in the first
place
specialist teams have now been brought
in to carry out detailed searches
of properties and land around this
traveler's site
where it's believed firearms may be
hidden
those searches are expected to last at
least a couple of days
mark white sky news